[Music]
he is one of the most important
political figures of the 20th century
and even though Fidel Castro's death had
been announced prematurely many times
before
this time the passing of Cuba's
legendary leader was announced by his
brother on state television you go where
all they all were dear people of Cuba
it's with profound sadness that I must
share this without people our friends
and the world that today November 25th
10 29 at 9 2016 the commander and chief
of the Cuban Revolution Fidel Castro
died he was the revolutionary who
managed to be a thorn in America's side
for half a century Fidel Castro was
leader of the first communist country in
the Western Hemisphere an iconic figure
who became a rarely-seen recluse in
recent years due to old age and ill
health Castro came to power in 1959
after overthrowing the us-backed
dictator Fulgencio Batista he embraced
the Soviet Union and its leader Nikita
Khrushchev America tried and failed to
overthrow Castro the Bay of Pigs in 1961
but relations sunk to an all-time low
with the Cuban Missile Crisis a year
later before dismantling you could see
fueling and oxidizer vehicles -
launchers and missile ready tents
America obtained evidence the Soviets
were setting up nuclear-armed missiles
on the Caribbean island it shall be the
policy of this nation to regard any
nuclear missile launched from Cuba
against any nation in the Western
Hemisphere as an attack by the Soviet
Union on the United States America then
tried to isolate Cuba through a
crippling trade embargo and over the
years legend has it the CIA tried to
assassinate Castro more than 600 times
even
packing his cigars with explosives when
the Soviet Union collapsed so too did
Cuba's subsidies prompting food queues
and a waterborne exodus of Cubans to
Florida opening up tourism helped the
Cuban economy to soldier on Castro
clamped down and dissenting voices
jailing his opponents and restricting
private ownership his social welfare
program and universal education won him
popular support he was revered amongst
the left of Latin America and continued
to enjoy
iconic status until his health began to
decline Romney during a speech at a
rally in 2001 Fidel Castro had to be
helped off stage three years later a
fool left him with a fractured knee and
arm but after abdominal surgery in 2006
he started the transfer of power to his
brother Raul who took the landmark step
in 2014 to appear simultaneously with
Barack Obama to announce attempts to
normalize relations between the two
countries but I believe that we can do
more to support the Cuban people and
promote our values through engagement
after all these 50 years have shown that
isolation has not worked the arrival of
an American president on Cuban soil
would have been unthinkable in 50 years
on the Castro's iron rule but it was he
who made the seemingly impossible in
2016
on the streets of Miami there has been
celebration following the news of
Castro's death many here are the sons
and daughters of the Cuban exiles who
fled the oppression of the small
Caribbean states the other side of the
story of a man who will be lionized in
his death
as he was during his life Castro was
both dictator and liberated Fidel Castro
leaves Cuba albeit a changing country as
a one-party state still in the hands of
the Castro family harshest Russia Sky
News